from a director named Ingmar Bergman
often to be most eloquent is to be
silent you're quite right
the film we've just seen is said at all
I think we should say that those
nominated for the best performance by an
actor are Marlon Brando in The Godfather
Michael Caine in sleuth Laurence Olivier
in sleuth Peter O'Toole in the ruling
class paul winfield in sounder the
winner is Marlon Brando in The Godfather
accepting the award for
this shocking
hello my name is sashing Littlefeather
I'm Apache and I'm president of the
National Native American affirmative
image committee I'm representing Marlon
Brando this evening and he has asked me
to tell you in a very long speech which
I cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award and the reasons for this
being are the treatment of American
Indians today by the film industry
excuse me
and on television in movie reruns and
also with recent happenings at Wounded
Knee I beg at this time that I have not
intruded upon this evening and that we
will in the future our hearts and our
understandings will meet with love and
generosity thank you on behalf of Marlon
Brando